all right it's time to play word
association here on pft live and we're
going to begin
with a great former running back warwick
dunn who now i think owns a small piece
of the atlanta falcons giving devonta
freeman falcons running back some free
advice take fewer hits first thing that
comes to mind for you when you hear that
like uh yoda you know old wise yoda oh
great you know sorcerer you're on your
own fewer hits you will take yeah
exactly right and you know hey there's
two florida state running backs and uh
you know this is a great advice by a guy
like work done devante freeman's had
some injuries and he's banged up and he
plays a physical style he devonte
freeman thinks he's 255 pounds that's
the the biggest problem with devonte
freeman and work done is just trying to
tell him hey limit those car crash hits
a little bit and you'll squeeze a few
more years out of your career
i want to hear your yoda impersonation
because i have a feeling it's phil sims
trying to impersonate you oh man i don't
know if i can really actually do that
florio is jerk is he not or is he
something like that i don't know what it
is you know that's actually close enough
to be mildly entertaining for me the
response is duh of course you got to
take fewer hits that's how it works in
the nfl especially at running back you
call them car crashes and aptly so you
need to take fewer of them and you need
there are certain number of them that
are unavoidable the ones that are
avoidable are the ones you need to avoid
that's the easy solution you don't have
to prove that you're a tough guy every
time you put that helmet on and you put
the shoulder pads on you are
implied to be a tough guy you don't have
to go out there and impose your will
physically that's how you get yourself
injured so get out of bounds get down
find a way to avoid taking hits that can
be avoided we can't avoid all of them
but the more of the avoidable hits that
can indeed indeed be dodged those are
the ones that you have to
avoid
avoid avoid avoid avoid the things you
can avoid and don't avoid the things you
can't avoid basically that's my that's
my advice thank you very well said
all right moving right along adrian
peterson has his sights set on another 2
000 yard
rushing season that's his goal for 2019
your your word association in response
to that uh delusional okay that's where
i'm gonna go with that i mean it's
delusional like in a good way because i
appreciate the self-confidence that this
guy has all the time and that's why he
is you know in the conversation for one
of the greatest running backs in the
history of the sport and you know it's
his delusions that make him continue to
work and believe in himself and all that
so i'm not certainly mad at the fact
that he said that i mean this is what
makes great players like adrian peterson
so great but i mean darius geiss is
going to be back in the fold this year
it's just you know uh extra i don't
think it's realistic to think that
adrian peterson could get to 2000 yards
at this point of his career if he gets
to a thousand uh it's almost as good as
getting to 2000 nine years ago or eight
years ago like he did
mine is very simple never bet against
adrian peterson i don't care what it is
if he said three thousand i would say
never bet against adrian peterson now
well he's been
i remember after he got to 2000 in 2012
his goal was 2500. so there's a certain
amount of delusion that i think is
necessary to go out there and function
you have to be so confident in yourself
that you do cross that line into
delusion at times that's part of the
swagger that you have to have in order
to even get to the nfl you have to
believe big in yourself if you don't who
will so hey he shoots for 2000 and he
ends up with 1300 that's still a damn
good year for adrian peterson i have no
problem with people setting big goals
and having big dreams because you don't
get medium goals or medium dreams unless
you have big goals and big dreams or
something no question i'm with you there
mike cowboys running backs coach gary
brown on ezekiel elliott's recent run-in
with a security guard at the music
festival in las vegas where the security
guard ended up on the ground the
security guard wants a a real apology
from ezekiel elliott and gary brown says
zeke knows he's got to be smarter word
association well i'm going to go with
one of the the brilliant things you've
said today duh i mean yes of course he
does i mean that was just such a bad
look and again it wasn't the most
egregiously bad thing ever you know i
mean again you know ezekiel elliott i i
sure surely hope the nfl doesn't pose
any fines or suspensions on him i don't
think it was worthy of that but
regardless it was a bad luck i mean a
bad look he's too too big of a star at
this point of his career he's too close
to getting
big time rich and changing his life and
his whole family's life here very soon
to be walking around some parking lot in
las vegas and a lebron james jersey and
who knows what time of the night getting
in the face of a security guard that's
it's just not a good look come on man
you're too big of a start to be doing
that and honestly i i think they're
dropping the ball right now like zeke or
somebody they should do something cool
on social media to make it up to that
security guard he said he wanted the
apology maybe he's already done it uh i
don't know i know ezekiel it's a very
good guy you can't hear you can't find
dallas cowboy people to say two bad
things about him so i don't doubt that
uh but i thought it would be kind of
cool opportunity maybe have that guy
down to otas and have him be a part of
the team and zeke takes some pictures of
them having fun i thought the cowboys
might do something like that to kind of
repair the image a little hey i'm going
to flip this back around on gary brown
and say look in the mirror right gary
brown's got to be smarter because gary
brown knows ezekiel elliott as well as
anyone and the mere fact that this
happened the mere fact that this
incident occurred tells me gary brown
isn't hammering it into ezekiel
elliott's brain the way that he needs to
to avoid these situations you are on the
nfr's radar screen even if we disagree
with the the fairness of the procedure
from two years ago that resulted in the
six game suspension and even if even if
there are are real flaws with how the
nfl handled everything the nfl has
suspended him six games in the past he's
a repeat offender if he gets in trouble
again so it's on gary brown not just to
make sure that ezekiel elliott is at his
best on the field but to make sure that
he's at his best off the field and
there's got whether it's brown or
somebody else there's got to be a
mechanism within the cowboys
organization that ensures that ezekiel
elliott is making good decisions and not
putting himself in a compromising
position and the mere fact that he was
tells me somebody has failed and if gary
brown is going to be the one to come out
and lecture to ezekiel elliott i'll
lecture to gary brown you should have
been in a position to be smarter about
what it takes to keep ezekiel elliott
out of trouble
wow yeah i
it's tough you would you would hope that
i know i look i know that a grown-ass
man is responsible for his own life
right but but when you are responsible
for that man and when you have a vested
interest in that man being available to
play for you when you know there's a
history of bad decisions allegedly or
actually then you need to make sure that
you're helping him make good decisions
that's one thing that astounds me about
nfl teams that a lot of them don't do
enough
to help the guys who clearly are a
potential risk of getting themselves in
trouble it's gotten better in recent
years definitely but that only makes it
more glaring chris when there's a guy
who already has been in trouble with the
league who gets himself in a situation
where he now has to sweat out what the
league's going to do about this one yeah
no i i hear you there mike and you know
sometimes i think what you're saying is
just it's simple phone call every now
and then or it's a reminder hey hey it's
thursday night i know the players got
friday saturday and sunday off hey zeke
just checking in on you hope you had a
good weekend just remind you man we got
big things in front of us you know be
smart this weekend take care of yourself
the people around you whatever it is
sometimes it's all of that all you need
is a player just one more good voice in
your head before the weekend starts when
you're 24 25 years old and you're just
thinking oh man this is going to be fun
i'm going to do this this weekend that
this weekend man those fun weekends can
lead to some problems in a hurry i could
tell you that i've been a part of a few
of them you never know what moment that
that voice of reason is going to
ricochet back into the middle of your
brain to keep you from getting in
someone's face while someone is
recording you and so i i st
ultimately each individual is
responsible for his or her own life but
if you're going to have other people
responsible for you and they're going to
lecture that you need to be smarter well
you need to be smarter too because you
clearly didn't do enough to help this
guy or he wouldn't have gotten himself
in trouble in the first place all right
brian schottenheimer says the seahawks
are still a running team word
association no school like the old
school mike that's my word association
i mean first of all pete carroll's old
school in the way that he wants to play
football running the ball playing
defense right they also want to get back
to the old school of that's what got
them to the super bowl and got them to
the second super bowl that they lost and
were a yard away should have ran the
ball on that damn play too but
regardless
this is the way pete carroll and the
seattle seahawks want to play football
and again i think this is the new trend
i think we're going to continue to see
in football the old school is coming
back because nobody does the old school
anymore the old school has become the
new school because high school football
i go watch that college football i watch
that it's spread it's the quarterback
and the shotgun and we're seeing teams
like the seahawks the saints the rams
the new england patriots are going oh
all these defensive players they're so
used to the spread with high school
college football what do they are they
do they know what it's like to have a
fullback and a tailback coming downhill
with a pulling guard and smash mouth
football the answer to that's no and i
think some of the smart coaches in
football have realized that and
seattle's gonna continue to try to play
the way they did when they were uh one
of the best teams in football and just
ask russell wilson to make some magic a
few times a game to get them over the
edge in the past game
my reaction is i'll believe it when i
see it because i can't reconcile what
schottenhamer said with paying russell
wilson a contract that is worth 35
million per year in new money you don't
need to spend that much on a quarterback
if you're not going to use them and i
think there's going to be a feeling
within the organization we have to
justify this money we can't just let
russell wilson hand off handoff handoff
we could get a quarterback to hand off
for a hell of a lot less than 35 million
a year so look i i don't rule out the
possibility that they're just setting us
up to think that they're going to run
the football a lot and from time to time
they're going to reserve the right to
come out with four receivers spread out
and russell wilson in the shotgun as
long as they don't do it from the
one-yard line with the super bowl on the
line then maybe they'll find a way to
diversify the offense a bit more but i
think that the more they can cause their
opponents to think they're moving one
way sure and go the other way that that
that could be all the different you know
if you just surprise people the first
two or three weeks of the season if you
have your opponents thinking that you're
going to be one way and you stun them
enough to steal a couple of wins right
out of the gates that could change
everything as the season unfolds so
whatever the seahawks do maybe they are
going to run the ball maybe we are going
to be saying all season long why the
hell did you pay russell wilson so much
money if you're not going to throw the
ball more than 15 or 20 times a game
regardless i feel like the seahawks are
going to be a real factor in
2019.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports